and this is just for anybody watching at
the end of the day
the simple breakdown
i provide for people is
if you're if you're if you're a man
for any man in this room if i was to sit
here and break down a woman so for
example
i would say she's
she's very very caring she loves her
career yeah right she's very very driven
she's got loads of friends around her
that love and respect that her family
adores the pieces highly educated
what is every single man in this room
thinking right now
in what sense
if i was to describe a woman and start
off and purely
lay out those
um
attributes or traits or her history
right what what for any guy in here or
any guy listening what question do you
have in mind what's the first question
you have what does she look like thank
you very much right it all comes down to
the aesthetics in the beginning right
now for women
it is slightly different in that
now if i was to say
he's
a great looking guy
chisel jaw
big dick
tall
why
what does he do for us thank you very
much
you've broke so the first thing you want
to know who is he what does he do what
his connections what's his status right
in society
i think deep down every single woman
asks those questions and if i was to say
along with those things
if i was to drop it on you now say that
he's a complete bum he's going nowhere
in life he still lives in his mom's
basement and he's got no drive to
accomplish anything in life nobody
around him respects him he's got no
friends and there's no girls trying to
hit him up what would you say now
get the [ __ ] away from me is what you're
saying
i always say like we shouldn't say
hypergamy isn't a bad thing like what
is designed for our survival yeah
exactly i don't want to date a bomb like
i i hope to god you guys don't want to
date bombs so you're saying guys would
like a girl who's bummy yes
or at least
what a girl a woman being a bum to us we
don't really look at women as bums for
us it's more to do with your loyalty
yeah and it's to do with your attitude
in life whether you're arrogant whether
you've got that
overly confident nature to us it's
repulsive but a woman having no money
and a woman not being well connected do
you think we give a [ __ ] because that's
not our ultimate goal
ultimately on a dna level and this is
what most men need to understand this is
what we act on it's primal so on a dna
level we are ultimately after
good breeding stocks so you need to have
and this is this is a woman's display of
good breeding stock good genes is by
having a great physique a beautiful face
she's youthful she's young she's within
that peak fertility window
she does have a clock and sooner or
later that will run out and then she'll
she'll end up on the other side of that
where
men are now not looking at her for sex
they're not looking for biological
reasons maybe for
value as far as being a great nanny or
for example being great with kids being
valuable in different areas but we are
not looking at you and thinking
i am going to get good good kids with
good jeans out of you once you're past
that window and that is even more so for
menopause
yeah because geriatric pregnancy starts
at 35. so your options start to run out
they don't recommend having a kid over
what like 37 38. nice
from the studies i've read is between
around 1617 to around
early 30s is when they say it's a
woman's peak fertility yeah well and the
problem is you have rich people pushing
a luxury lifestyle on average people
like geriatric or um ivf which is
something like girls always say it's 25
000 who has that lying around
and you have rich people that can do
that right like the kardashians they all
had kids later in life they're fine but
it's because they could afford to the
average girls can't do that and so you
have feminism pushing like chase the bag
chase the career get ran through and and
basically piss away your the most
valuable thing you have which is your
youth and your fertility not only that
pearl what what tends to happen is that
i feel like there's an agenda
in terms of there is a benefit to to
certain people that women are single
not in control of their finances
spending and they've got money so
they've got they've got
a lot of money coming in
they're not tied down
but they're spending money somewhere so
yeah because seven women make 70 to 80
of consumer buying decisions
and so there is an agenda in keeping
women single right because you're not
going to buy no big birking bag when
you're in the race well women women
women make less money but spent own
two-thirds of the world's debt even
though we make 10 to 15 000
pounds
less than men per year
and so we have less money and we spend
more hundred percent i never thought
about it
yeah we're impulsive yeah yeah but it's
because we're chemically different we
can't
we can't help it we have salt we're
adults but like like on some primal
level we're chemically different every
day
so
like we're more like emotional beings
yeah yeah we're more likely to respond
to to make impulsive decisions that's
what it is
and your friends are not going to help
you because she wants to make those
decisions as well so it's like the only
person that's really there is the guy
that's just like the cheap guy that we
called it you know what i'm saying he's
controlling the final like no you can't
keep doing this babes like you know i
mean like we can't afford it we need
distant distant distances that came
through the lid no that's a little
that's why we date higher in it so i
have a question for the women
would you okay if you had a guy
i i don't i know it varies for every
girl so imagine a guy that has every
single thing that you want like perfect
guy
would you overlook cheating
from time to time just a side check no i
would you would you'd overlook it i
wouldn't you wouldn't even if also your
bills are taken care of completely till
you die i wouldn't you wouldn't okay
i wouldn't um if i had kids it might be
different but i didn't say too yeah if i
didn't have kids
um and i was still i felt like
if i was still like maybe my age now
um
yeah i wouldn't overlook it because a
trait that i look for is loyalty
and
for me i understand that the male nature
is to spread his seed you know go find
out what like what he wants
and
yeah so i i can understand that but i
also think that
them given into that nature of you know
like even if it didn't mean anything it
was just like a one-night stand you know
he was just caught up in the moment
that to me would
be like you're you're a weak man you
can't hold like especially if we had
something really good going on
and we had a really good relationship
we've been together a really long time
and
and then you just [ __ ] up one night
like that to me is disrespectful to me
and then i wouldn't go back with you
because
now you would probably do that again
because i've accepted that that's how
you are now you [ __ ] up from time to
time can i just ask have you been in
that position before
no i've never been done
that you know what you know of i was
just gonna say
so for you why did you say yes
i don't believe that men
can not cheat okay and when i say men i
mean most men
i think i think i think they're just
built to
i think that you're dating the twenty
percent you mean we're not designing
they're not designed to be with one
person don't say we're not designed to
cheat
because you're assuming that the woman
is
like somehow like deserving of just me
alone no no what makes you think she's
she said on desire to be monogamous but
no no that's not her words let her say
what she's saying she said she let her
talk she said cheat guys let her talk go
ahead
as many of you know i was just banned on
tick tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible